[Musik]
wie um ihre schande vergessen zu machen
wie sie im ghetto keinen stein auf dem
anderen
nur ein einsamer kirchturm ragte aus
meter hohe schuld nach polen waren die
deutschen gekommen nicht um zu siegen
sondern um zu vernichten
polen als staat sollte verschwinden fast
wäre ihnen das gelungen
[Musik]
es handelt sich nicht um militärische
ziele es geht nicht darum jetzt ordnung
in der stadt zu schaffen sondern es ging
darum diese stadt auszulöschen
doch die besetzer hatten die rechnung
ohne die polen gemacht kaum waren die
besatzer weg kam sie langsam ans licht
[Musik]
maria schoo stoffe und sophia schor mit
tosca waren mittendrin die beiden
fotografinnen bahnten sich den weg durch
die altstadt von warschau kletterten
über die trümmer des ghettos passten auf
dass sie nicht verschütt ging mit der
kamera machen sie inventur sie hielten
fest was fehlte und was noch da war
den fahrradladen unter freiem himmel das
fotogeschäft in einem ausgebrannten
straßenbahn waggon die ersten straßen
märkte mit neuen kartoffeln schön
anzusehen aber fast unbezahlbar teuer
eines ihrer lieblingsmotive war der
erste schönheitssalon und sollte
warschau auch in trümmern liegen so
konnte man herauslesen
die frauen der stadt kam schnell wieder
auf die beine
diese bilder prägen bis heute das denken
der pool die polen denken an deutschland
zuerst mit dem klicks perspektive das
muss man doch deutlich sagen wenn ein
pole deutschland oder die deutschen hört
da sagt er zuerst kriegsverbrecher
hitler konzentrationslager otto hofmann
ist kein besonders religiöser mann aber
auf dem weg zu diesen stufen werden alle
stimmen er fragt dem alten jüdischen
brauch und legt einen stein am mahnmal
im warschauer ghetto
früher war das sinnvoll um die wilden
tiere von den gräbern abzuhalten
hoffmann ist einer von 20.000 polnischen
juden von 1 3 millionen
seine familie hat den holocaust in der
sowjetunion überlebt
hier hatte seinen echten aufstand gegen
die nazis gegeben
aus wut und verzweiflung mit
hunderttausenden von toten und niemand
kam zur hilfe
die deutschen haben entschädigung für
israel gezahlt und nun meint nur die
jüngere generation das reicht und
ansonsten schuldeten sie niemand etwas
schon gar nicht den juden und den polen
und vor allem nicht den polnischen juden
vor 50 jahren ging hier ein mann in die
knie
der schon damals wusste dass man vor
seiner schuld nicht weglaufen kann und
wer war besser dafür geeignet als er der
es eigentlich nicht nötig hatte willy
brandt der deutsche bundeskanzler hatte
niemanden eingeweiht auch seine engsten
berater nicht näherkommen registrierten
wir es wurde plötzlich
mucksmäuschenstill
für die juden in der welt und nicht nur
für sie kam diese geste wie eine
erlösung juden wussten
selbstverständlich dass willy brandt
nach norwegen gegangen war und sich dem
widerstand angeschlossen hatte brand das
war ein guter deutscher der abstecher
zum ghetto war nicht geplant stand nicht
im protokoll
willy brandt war auf staatsbesuch in der
damaligen volksrepublik polen
auf dem besuch im ehemaligen ghetto
hatte willy brandt persönlich gedrängt
keiner der gastgeber sprach ihn darauf
an
es herrschte betretenes schweigen konnte
dann lässt sich nicht anderes tun als
zeichen zu setzen ich bitte als einer
der nun nicht zu den wildesten anhängen
etwas gehört hat um es mal so zu sagen
ich bitte für mein volk und welt sein
bete auch darum dass man uns verzeihen
will
der damalige außenminister walter scheel
der ihn begleitete erinnert sich er hat
mit dieser symbol handlung für das
ansehen der deutschen der welt mehr
getan als viele regierungen insgesamt
mit ihrem mit ihrem guten willen und
ihrer guten politik bewirkt haben brandt
war gekommen um den polen die angst vor
deutschen gebietsansprüchen zu nehmen
seine neue ostpolitik verzichtete auf
ehemals deutsche gebiete brand hatte zu
hause die vertriebenen die im verrat
vorwarfen
polen war nach 1945 wieder mal spielball
der großen mächte das land wurde um
hunderte kilometer nach westen
verschoben
die schraffierten flächen im osten
musste es an russland abgeben die
schraffierten flächen im westen
ostpreußen pommern und schlesien bekam
polen als ausgleich zig millionen
menschen mussten ihre koffer packen
die grenzen sollten nun 25 jahre nach
kriegsende vertraglich gesichert werden
damals wurden die verträge über die
endgültige westgrenze polens entlang von
oder und neiße unterzeichnen
das war sehr wichtig für den platz
polens und deutschlands in europa und es
ging fast schon wieder zivilisiert das
schicksal der polnischen juden war
offiziell kein thema in warschau 1970
die wunden waren noch zu frisch
einer der wenigen überlebenden erinnerte
sich dankbar an brandts geste das neue
deutschland hatte sich endlich zu seiner
verantwortung bekannt
brand auf dem gebiet des ehemaligen
warschauer
und zwar genau auf dem platz auf dem
zaun mein leben und meiner frau
entschieden hat da sind wir raus geführt
wurden
da würden wir ausgeführt und wir wussten
noch nicht nach links das heißt zum
umschlagplatz und zur vergasung oder
nach rechts dann durften wir noch etwas
am leben bleiben
mehr als eine halbe million menschen
wurden hier zusammengefasst die eine
hälfte starb die andere später in den
gaskammern
[Musik]
wir wissen heute dass sie zu leicht
davon gekommen dass die deutschen nicht
genug bestraft worden für all das was
sie gemacht haben
besonders in diesem teil europas dieses
gefühl dass deutschland zu billig davon
gekommen ist sitzt tief die
nationalkonservative regierung peace
west seit jahren rechnen und rechnen da
kommt schnell eine billion euro zusammen
warschau sieht auf den ersten blick
nicht so aus wie eine stadt die
reparationen nötig hätte eine sehr
moderne stadt und entsprechend zieht es
zwischen den wolkenkratzern
die züge sind pünktlich der import liegt
bei 250 milliarden dollar im jahr
der export auch wer jetzt noch von polen
wirtschaft also chaos und mängeln
spricht macht sich lächerlich oder war
länger nicht mehr da mit dem wohlstand
kommen andere sorgen wo es brot genug
gibt soll es auch gerecht
polen hat sechs millionen menschen
verloren warum wissen nur wenige in der
welt vom leid der polin wurde ihre sache
nicht gut verfochten
und er wollte es niemand hören es gibt
kaum einen kilometer entfernt vom
ehrenmal der juden ein ort der lehrt
dass man große verbrechen verschweigen
kann aber nicht auf dauer als die
polnische autorin monika sogar ein kind
war
waren diese helden und person kein wort
habe sie in der schule von den helden
des warschauer aufstands gehört das war
zu den kommunistischen zeiten undenkbar
das wäre undenkbar gewesen dass so ein
denkmal
weil die landes armee die den aufstand
organisierter sehr antikommunist sich
eingestellt wurden willy brandt hätte
die rebellion des bürgerlichen polens
also gar nicht ehren können das denkmal
gab es 1970 noch nicht auch dieser
aufstand ging verloren heldenhaft und
hoffnungslos auch hier kam niemand zu
hilfe
die sowjetarmee stand schon am anderen
ufer der weichsel griff aber nicht ein
unter denen aber auch solche leute die
auf die hilfe der russen die auf der
anderen seite der weichsel standen
gehofft hatten die russen kamen nicht
mit der hilfe die russen ließen also im
polnischen bewusstsein die russen ließen
eigentlich diesen aufstand die deutschen
eigentlich diesen aufstand und ganz
warschau einfach zerstören kaputtmachen
polen also wieder opfer wie schon so oft
beim wiederaufbau der wechselbrücke auf
sich allein gestellt und die nächste
enttäuschung stand bevor der große
bruder sagte die entschädigung des
westens ein
aber eigentlich sind die russen uns
dieses reparationen schuldig weil sie
uns weil die reparationen an polen
gingen an moskau und das waren so
vereinbart dass die russen uns ein teil
von den ganzen reparationen wie sie von
deutschland bekommen zurückgeben und das
haben sie natürlich nie gemacht also die
russen haben uns betrogen indem sie die
polin schafften es aus eigener kraft die
altstadt aufzubauen
das dauerte bis mitte der 60er jahre das
know-how machte sie zu begehrten
experten für den wiederaufbau auch
außerhalb wer sich fragt warum die
altstadt fast wie eine filmkulisse
aussieht finanzierende vergangen vielen
älteren polen blieb der mund versiegelt
wenn sie an die zeiten der warschauer
aufstände denken etwa der familie von
krzysztof ruchniewicz der als historiker
nun all das zusammenträgt was mutter und
großmutter zeitlebens nicht in worte
fassen konnten
als kind damals konnte sie sich nur an
die grünen erinnern
sie konnte sich nur an ratten die noch
nie witz beschäftigt sich als
wissenschaftler mit der frage der
reparation es ist ein langer streit
schon von der brand regierung forderte
man summen mit sehr vielen nullen
der historiker sagt deutschland hat etwa
drei milliarden gezahlt das sei genug
die forderung der polnischen regierung
nach reparationen ist heute passiert
wir haben keinen anspruch mehr auf die
reparationen auf der suche nach der
angemessenen geste dem richtigen zeichen
landet man irgendwann an dieser ruine
dem anhalter bahnhof finden
eine polnisch deutsche initiative kämpft
darum dass hier entsteht was wirklich
fehlt ein denkmal für die sechs
millionen polen die unter deutscher
besatzung den tod fanden
das ist so etwas mehr als sieben
jahrzehnte nach kriegsende nicht gibt
spricht für sich selbst
das leiden unseres östlichen mittelmeer
östlichen nachbarn polen das ist wie ein
blinder fleck hinter these sammeln sich
politiker fast aller parteien aber nur
ein drittel aller bundestagsabgeordneten
was könnt ihr seid eine geschichte mit
diesen teil polens erst in breslau
geboren und mit zwei jahren nahmen ihnen
die eltern auf der flucht mit revanche
gefühl hat er nicht aber er warnt davor
auf zu rechnen wenn polen mit
milliarden-forderungen kommt entsteht
ein verrückter fährt kannst
unangemessener unangenehm da zwang auf
deutscher seite zu berechnen was frau
ostpreußen was kann man was schließen
wert gewesen ist gewissermaßen als gegen
rechnung und sich daran erinnern dass
schließen einmal die einst der
preußische provinz war
deutschland leistet sich seit 1980 ein
eigenes polen institut das regelmäßig
die stimmungslage auslotet es geht nicht
nur um das geld es geht um die
polnischen gefühle oder fragen um die
polnischen opfer ob das leid polen so
richtig anerkannt wurde ob das alle
wissen was die polen gelitten haben
darum geht es zuerst in den polnischen
diskussion oder bei den polen die an den
krieg denken es ist die sorge die
deutschen haben das schon vergessen oder
mann
will in deutschland nicht die ganze
wahrheit sagen wie vertrackt das alles
ist
wir treffen arthur hoffmann wieder
erwartet mit einer kleinen überraschung
auf der kniefall von warschau ist ein
weltereignis eines der wichtigsten
momente der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte
aber hat es zur deutsch polnischen
versöhnung beigetragen dass brandt vor
dem denkmal der juden kniete hofmann hat
herausgefunden dass willy brandts geste
im kommunistischen polen fast
totgeschwiegen wurde nur eine einzige
zeitung die jüdische volksstimme druckte
das bild
ich hätte mich installiert worden
als mir bewusst wurde dass unsere zeit
um die einzige war
dies veröffentlichte da war mir auch
klar warum das war knapp zwei jahre
durch der antisemitischen hetze nach den
unruhen von 1968 und es war eine geste
die die kommunisten befangen werden
sie wussten nicht was damit anzufangen
kaum ein pole hat den kniefall gesehen
ausgerechnet nach polen hat er kaum
gewirkt die welle des antisemitismus
wurde ganz oben gestartet und breitete
sich dann nach ulm aus meisten
polnischen juden verließen das land nach
1968 und die treibende kraft des exodus
war genau der herr gomolka der mit willy
brandt die verträge unterzeichnete bei
näherem hinsehen werden die meisten
dinge einfacher bei der deutsch
polnischen geschichte ist das nicht denn
vielleicht ist es zeit wieder für eine
solche geste die dann aber möglichst
alle mitbekommen
[Musik]